well the hits keep coming for Facebook
first the company was rocked by the
revelation that Cambridge analytical
harvested the data of 50 million users
without proper authorization now the
company itself is accused of shady data
collection shockingly a company whose
entire business model is built on spying
may have been spying on people over the
weekend
Ars Technica reported that Facebook
collected contacts text messages of the
private data from Android phone users
without their knowledge
Rodger McNamee is co-founder of
elevation partners he was an early
investor in Facebook and a mentor to
Mark Zuckerberg he's now a sometim
critic of the company he joins us
tonight Roger thanks for coming up happy
to be here Tucker so it mean my one
sentence take on this is it seems like
the rest the country is waking up to the
the basic nature of Facebook which is it
spies on you no I think that the issue
is exactly as you framed it the the
business model which is based on
advertising requires them to know as
much as they can about every single user
and what you don't know and what you
can't tell is a user is that they're
using every tool available and Android
phones as Ars Technica pointed out have
a feature that allows a product like
Facebook to download all of your
contacts all of your texts and Facebook
goes well someday we may be able to
monetize that we're just going to grab
it while it's there and a lot of people
discover to their chagrin that it's not
just Cambridge analytic in fact from
2010 to 2014 there were at least tens of
thousands and maybe hundreds of
thousands of applications that did the
same thing they harvested all of these
are data that was out there without the
permission of the users so I mean that
information those data give Facebook
more power over you than for example any
governments ever had over American
citizens should we be worried about that
power well I believe that that's the
kind of power that requires great
judgment and the thing that we've seen
in recent months is that Facebook's
judgment around its power has been
really poor and I personally as somebody
who mentored them who was involved as
investor who was at one time
extraordinarily proud of it
my tenure there which was from 2006 to
2009
was before the company had really
developed a business model and so I was
withdrawn while this stuff was going on
and as I came to understand what was
going on I felt it was important to
reach out to Mark Zuckerberg and Sheryl
Sandberg and make them aware of it which
I did in 2016 and that it's hard when
you're in the position they're in to
recognize that your baby has suddenly
become a huge problem but I'm afraid it
has and candidly I'm glad these
revelations are coming out because we
need them to change their strategy so
Android users found that they're being
spied on by Facebook do you think we're
gonna learn that Apple users are being
spied on as well no Apple has a
different architecture so I think that
probably not I think the sad thing is
we're gonna discover if you're an
Android user it's not just Facebook
who's spying on you right the difference
is in Apple's model because the people
pay directly to Apple when they buy the
phone Apple treats those people as the
customer with Android it's the phone
company that's the customer and so just
as in Facebook where the advertiser is
the customer and the user is the product
the user of the phone to Android is also
a product and it that's the problem with
the model it's that they aren't treating
us like humans they're treating us like
the fuel to generate profits and
candidly I think that has to stop I
think all of Silicon Valley needs to
reassess why it's in business and
recognize that they can be incredibly
profitable they can still be
billionaires without stripping the
privacy from everybody and selling it to
the highest bidder well I mean it took
40 years for the government to respond
to the health effects of tobacco which
weren't recognized at first people it's
only dawned on people and then the
government took action how long will it
take our government to respond to the
bad effects on our society of Facebook
and Google well to be clear Tucker I
don't think the best responsibly the one
from the government I think the best
responsibly from the users and from the
employees of these companies I don't
think the employees understood exactly
what the companies were doing and I
think as they understand it they're
gonna appreciate that wait a minute that
is not something they want to be part of
and I think you're gonna see some kind
of pushback and rebellion one of the
things we've been trying to encourage
the employees of Facebook and some of
these other companies to do is to
recognize that hey wait a minute these
are great ideas
these companies make great products but
the advertising business model has
terrible incentives and and literally
billions of people are being hurt by it
not just in the US but around the world
and that frankly they can be successful
without doing that stuff and it's up
it's on the employees to fix it because
let's face it the government is not
gonna be able to fix this on a time
frame that's gonna make any difference
well that's a good point they're not
even trying I hope that happens thank
you for that we're out of time but I my
pleasure Tucker your knowledge and your
candor